Концтабір був ой! Боже…
Жорсточайший голод,
холод
і непосильна фізична праця.
Я вижив, тому що був молодий.
А такі, які були старші, всі загинули.
Цей малюнок 93-річний львів’янин Онуфрій Дудок
намалював кілька років тому. Каже, захотів вилити
на папір біль, який не відпускає його вже багато років.
Це він у каменярнях концтабору "Флоссенбюрг".
Величезне каміння на плечах.
Носити зранку до ночі без зупинок,
під наглядом людей із нагайками.
Треба було...
дивитися на нього, чи він не дивиться на тебе.
Якщо він дивиться на тебе, ти мусиш працювати
скоро, бо інакше приходить і б’є…
Онуфрій Дудок опинився в нацистській Німеччині в 1942 році.
Закінчивши сільську школу, він працював
на торфозаготівлі поблизу Львова.
Нацисти забрали його прямо звідти, посадили на потяг
і відправили на примусові роботи до Нюрнберга.
Можливо, він би і не опинився в концтаборі,
якби одного дня без дозволу наглядачів
не пішов на пошту відправити листа батькам,
які не знали, куди саме подівся їхній син.
Його затримало гестапо Нюрнберга.
Згодом відправили до концтабору Флоссенбюрг.
Ось опис особистих речей, які він мав при собі.
Шапка, штани, сорочка, взуття, робоча куртка.
У німецьких архівах збереглися всі дані про в’язня
з тодішньої Галичини. Він значиться
"робочим" під номером 166 557.
Номер -
то в таборі
твоє ім’я та по-батькові.
Я стільки нагаїв отримував,
бо за першим викликом не відізвався.
Вдарить - то страшне. Страшенний біль.
Усього Онуфрій Дудок пережив ТРИ нацистські концтабори.
Спогади про минуле часто доводять його до сліз.
Іноді він уже не може загадати те, що ще недавно
розповідав дружині Галині.
З "Флоссенбюрга" Онуфрій потрапив до концтабору
"Аушвіц-Біркенау" в польському містечку Освенцім.
Ти пам’ятаєш, як ти був у Польщі?
Купа печива, щоб отруїти щурів.
Люди те з’їли і зразу повмирали.
А він тільки взяв один раз і все.
Онуфрій розповідає, що усіх із потяга, який привіз
його разом із іншими в’язнями молодого віку
до "Аушвіца", мали відправити одразу в крематорій.
Проте хтось із наглядачів помітив, що виснажені
чоловіки не є євреями та ще можуть попрацювати,
тож відправив їх до житлових бараків.
Ще раз уникнути смерті вдалося, коли якийсь
німецький офіцер вирішив не вбивати Онуфрія за те,
що той захворів і не міг працювати на розбірці
вагонів зі збитими літаками.
Смерть була скрізь. Чорний сморід від крематорію,
куди постійно заганяли людей. Онуфрій зізнається,
що за якийсь час уже був не здатен
на жодні людські емоції.
Мені вже нічого не треба було
Я чекав от-от, аби згинути
чи спалили, і все.
Одночасно з Онуфрієм в "Аушвіці", в іншому бараці,
була ось ця дівчинка. На фото їй не більше 3-х років.
Дитину привезли потягом із Мінська
й відправили в дитячий барак для медичних досліджень.
Маля зробили примусовим донором для німецьких солдатів.
В мене третя група (крові) -
не така активна.
Перша група - там дітей забирали і викачували всю кров.
Нині вже 84-річна киянка Анна Стрижкова
все ще достеменно не знає ані справжню дату свого народження,
ані звідки вона, хто її батьки та навіть імені,
яке їй дали при народженні.
Після звільнення концтабору деяких дітей
доправили до Києва. Там медична комісія
встановила, що Анні на той момент було 4 роки.
Від смерті через виснаження її врятували
прийомні батьки. Аби покращити стан дитини,
щоб вона хоча б почала ходити, мати віддавала їй
свою кров чотири рази.
Звісно, життя в таборі Анна Михайлівна заледве пам'ятає.
Натомість у пам'ять назавжди врізалося те,
що завдавало найбільшого болю.
Шок від того, як набивали номер на руці.
Обличчя тих, хто знущався над нею.
Ночами я кричала, бо часто мені снилася
наша...
наглядачка, яка водила нас на забір крові.
І якщо бачила білі халати,
я починала десь…
...кудись забитися.
А мати каже, що якщо лякаєшся, то кричи.
Я кажу: ні, кричати не можна, бо будуть бити.
У радянські часи в родині про концтабір не говорили.
Усвідомлювати, що з нею зробили в дитинстві,
Анна Михайлівна почала після закінчення інституту.
Вона стала мікробіологом.
А потім, вже в 1989 році,
коли на пострадянському просторі почали
піднімати тему в’язнів концтаборів,
Анна Михайлівна почала збирати про себе інформацію.
Втім, і сьогодні вона нічого не з'ясувала
про своїх справжніх батьків.
Знайти інформацію про колишніх в’язнів концтаборів,
попри досконалий порядок у нацистських архівах,
не завжди можливо, кажуть
у Міжнародному центрі жертв нацистських переслідувань "Архіви Арользена".
У деяких концтаборах було знищено багато документів,
хоча більшість усе-таки збереглися.
У Центрі досі фіксують по кількасот запитів
щоденно від людей, які хочуть знати про долю своїх близьких.
Часто це запити від школярів, які хочуть знати,
що коїли нацисти.
Онуфрія Дудка в Україні вже давно не запрошують
на уроки пам’яті. До нього не заходять
львівські школярі, як це було раніше. Натомість
запрошення регулярно надходять з-за кордону.
Онуфрій, каже його дружина, живе поїздками
до концтаборів. Попри свій вік він, зокрема,
обов’язково відвідує "Аушвіц" 27 січня -
у день річниці звільнення концтабору
радянськими військовими в 1945 році.